نتابع الان اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اشتدت حده المعارك في
الجبهات الجنوبيه والشرقيه بين الجيشين
الروسي
والاوكرانيلا سيما في جبهه مدينه
باغموت حيث قلم مؤسس فاجنر انه يسعى
لاستبدال قوته لوحدات عسكريه شيشانيه في
ظل استمرار تفجر الخلاف مع وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بسبب عدم توفير الذخيره لمواجهه
القوات الاوكرانيه
كما اكد مالك شركه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه
استمرار تقدم قواته في مدينه
وكشف ان معدات واليات واسلحه ومسيرات
غربيه بدات تصل بشكل متزايد الى جبات
بخموت وقال في تسجيل مصور من مدينه دخمت
انما تبقى تحت سيطره الاوكرانيين في
المدينه لا يتجاوز كيلومترين مربعين ونصف
الكيلومتر
ورائي مخموت لم يبقى سوى نحو كيلو مترين
ونصف كيلو مترين مربع هجوم واحد وسنسيطر
على المدينه نقص الذخيره لا يزال مستمرا
العدو يسحب باتجاه بخموت يوميا ما بين 400
الى 600 عسكريين وهذا هو عدده الخسائر
اليوميه من القوات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
تقريبا العدو لا يدخر الذخائر وقد ظهر
لديه ما يكفي من المدرعات الاجنبيه واعداد
كبيره من المسيرات النيران مشتعله في كل
مكان والمدفعيه لا تتوقف عن العمل ليلا
ونهارا انه حديث عن بخموت التي اصبحت
فاجنر لاند